very nice work there people very nice
work indeed oh thank you so much
your advice is very helpful well it's
like I tell every adult movie star if
you're going to suck suck all the way
mister honor working with you sir I've
never seen such brilliant direction well
what can I say I know how to keep him
coming
who was that ingeniously perverted man
that was Michael Bay the most brilliant
porn director the world has ever known
hello hey Michael it's Peter Peter so
good news good news buddy
we decided to let you direct bad boys if
all goes well we might have a few other
films lined up for you too they seep
attention
keep it up you might just be one of the
biggest action directors of all time oh
well that's great Peter that's great
what's the matter I thought you'd be
more excited oh I am Peter I am but I
just don't know if I always want to be
associated with action well what did you
have in mind well I always wanted to do
a romance
hello I'm gonna stealth remember it so
you don't have two years ago a disaster
though upon this nation horrible tragedy
that with good people and their families
scarred for life and well many weren't
there to witness it this attack on the
public left several poor souls confused
and the frame and I think we can all
agree it's a bombing we will never
forget and will hold deep within our
okay you know the punch lines Pearl
Harbor the movie not the actual event
some of you may find it kind of cold of
me to make a joke around that but if
Michael they can make up insulting shit
about Pearl Harbor well then so can i
this dumbass Flint trying to cash in on
the romantic historical fiction based
around a tragedy genre which they have
to say is quite a popular genre it's an
obvious studio choice to try and get out
a butch version of Titanic because hey
if the highest-grossing film at that
time got its profit from teary eyed
women naturally we can make more
marketing to testosterone-filled man
penis the problem is it's over three
hours long has no action until the
middle and is under the misconception
that Ben Affleck is likely and seeing
how this is still the month of love I
say we get snuggly with the most
romantic person we can think of Michael
Bay
let's awaken the sleeping giant with
Pearl Harbor we open with two boys on a
farm pretending to be pilots when one of
their dads comes in from his job
come what do you know it's one of those
one button Bush planes
it's a piloting school my ass blind this
thing's as easy as flushing a toilet
but father gherkin everything I'm in is
not happy and starts beating his son
only to have his friend knock him out I
still open you dirty German I fought the
Germans in France
I pray to God no one ever ecstasy things
that I saw
you
we are so long
we're not going anywhere yes way I have
no direction at all we do told you we
weren't going anywhere Wow me 30 years
later where those two boys have grown up
into some wild crazy rapscallions who
love pudding priceless military aircraft
in jeopardy most farm boys are grounded
yes sir an entirely unacceptable use of
military aircraft sir well I stood her
it's my thing it's a quick way to
identify me without having to give me
any character get those hedge hoppers in
Doolittle's office our heroes are played
by Ben Affleck pre director days so you
can hate them all you want and Josh
Hartnett with his eyes were any more
squinty would have to see through his
eyelids there under the command of
Colonel Doolittle played by Alec Baldwin
hurry I had too much pie but not post I
need to seriously stop eating the
goddamn pie it's ironic because he plays
a person based on a real-life Colonel
and yet he's probably the most cliche
character in the entire movie that's not
training McAuley that's a stunt and I
personally consider it to be reckless
and irresponsible I was doing it to try
to inspire the man sir and the way that
you've inspired me I believe the French
even have a word for that when the men
get together to honor their leaders they
call it an homage sir
what don't throw your million-dollar
words around me
well complicated French phrases are nuts
baguette chris'll to our de Partie no
Maj sense bullshit McCauley everybody
but it's very good ball just picture
yeah we like these privates that don't
follow commands and endanger their lives
and equipment we need more people like
you not doing what we tell you to do
it's like the old saying goes be all
that you can be and whatever you want
we're flexible oh man I'm one
good-looking son of a bitch though
seeing how Michael Bay's forecast calls
for permanent sunsets it's probably best
that we cut to the next night oh and
here's a fun game count how many times
they giggle throughout this entire sea
150 men that underwear every day we are
here to serve you know what they're
doing where I come from cow tipping Navy
nurses not tourists I tried to do my
patriotic duty and Tamika was getting
fresh so I poked him again ha
oh by the way hi Jennifer Garner yeah
that's really her before she became
famous yeah I wish you and these
brainless bimbos were all just aliases
for your next undercover mission you've
got to tell him the story everyone well
it was about four weeks ago yeah yeah so
Hartnett tries to help Affleck cheat the
physical so he can pass and join the
military but Kate catches on and calls
him on it but Army and Navy requires
20/20 vision
oh I it's not a problem with my eyes I
mean I can see it's just letters I mix
him up sometimes that's all I mean I
just get him backwards sometime well I
felt so bad I had no choice I passed him
well I guess it's nice that she passes
dyslexic doofus is putting most likely
several all their soldiers at risk in
critical times but all I want to know is
if he constantly gets letters and
numbers backwards all the time oh hell
did he lay the cheat sheet dipshit just
imagine those letters are up on the
board because guess what up on the board
maybe we could celebrate celebrate what
you being my hero for one they've course
starts chanting and start up a romance
but is it me or does it sound like Lucas
took over some of this romantic banter
here you are so beautiful it's your nose
that hurts
like it's my heart you're so beautiful
it's only because I'm so enough no it's
because I'm so in love with you so love
is blinded you maybe look it's a screen
aliases Randall Wallace what explains so
much so they spend days and days
together until we come to this tired
story threat the fact that he's leaving
the next day and it's only now telling
her about it I'm going to the war
tomorrow flying with the Eagle squadron
here in the US Army how could they order
you to go I volunteer I passed you know
you volunteer for the most dangerous
place you can go it's not your
responsibility now your choice yeah
we're just a couple it's not like you
have any say in things
it's like Rosie the Riveter says men
call all the shots
or was it something else no no that was
it but at least they have one last
romantic evening alone together or say I
can't do this but I can how about I want
to I don't want you to have anything
about tonight that you regret I had one
more night to live with you see that's
what I want I can't I want to know the
best part of my life still ahead of me
sue the promise of sex will bring you
home okay fair enough but you're still
gonna have that lust whether you're with
or tonight or not why buy the cow man or
deny the cow sex however the phrase goes
so he tells her not to see him off at
the train station but Gale of this great
logic it's my test
about telling not to come and she comes
anyway a nun I know she loved okay dude
you kept that you're leaving a secret
sprung it on her the night before say
she has no choice in the matter
are deny her no key and you have the
ball testicles to be testing her the
hell do you do for an encore tell
orphans that they're seeing Santa's
workshop but it's really a war zone and
the ones who didn't plug their ears get
a cookie Christ
how close are those Japanese planes
again
she loves me I totally made my
girlfriend who a tree badly cry feeling
the dick Shh
so what came their friends are off to be
nurses welcome ladies oh don't you need
t FY spends time in fighter jet while
also riding his supposed a true love
family girl sir big girl a lot of people
frown on the Yanks for not being in this
war yet I just like to say if there are
many more back home like you god help
anyone who goes to war with America oh
yeah another thing about this movie if
it could jerk off America's Hwang
anymore it probably could dick sauce on
Cuba haha but meanwhile our Japanese
enemies plot their surprise attack led
by God on high treasure to the entire
world in whatever parts of the universe
are left undiscovered Mako well Pearl
Harbor is too shallow for an aerial
torpedo attack we're surrounded by
subnets distance is our ally Admiral you
analysts got it all figured out don't
you smart enemy it's exactly what you
think you're saved
yes the smart enemy plots a giant hot
tubs with toy battleships to have no
markings on it that would identify it as
a map not of course forgetting oh so
sorry about the grow up
lots and lots more pick one goat on your
table
Vanda and I mean what about other sticks
and coffee Oh actually I have to admit
I'm kind of shocked we're about 45
minutes in and there's been no
explosions all character development
even it's bad development and even the
Asians are shown in non stereotypical
ways almost like Michael Bay was a
different guy still a bad director but a
different guy
you almost got wonder what's going
through his head at the time Peter did
you see the news about Armageddon no but
I've seen the critical feedback maybe
there wasn't much this big hit as I
thought actually according to these
recent box office results it's already
made 36 million
how can that be if one said it was crap
and yet it still made a spectacular
amount of money my phone has ever done
this much hatred letter and so much they
did this Michael Bay guys onto something
maybe he's a wonder kid it's a miracle
some are even calling him a son of
schlock
hey boson chosen one
you two have just been the best
roommates a man can have not only have
you been there to help me shoot all my
adult films but you've also been
supportive and I can't help but feel
you've had an impact on the way I view
the world man that'd be dope
Tina a in this rough brutal world that
we live in you've shown me all that
women are capable of it was a pleasure
to serve you mr. BAE and Dog Johnson
you've taught me what it means to keep
it real and never conform to the white
man's stereotype bitch we be keeping a
Hisi wissy in the pussy man indeed I
want you both to know that even though
I'm moving away to make bigger and
better films I will one day represent
each of you in the way you've had an
impact on me so what now G you keepin it
happen and poppin up in the hood Tahoe
Dawg whatever you just said no they
finally asked me to make the ultimate
romance epic that I've always wanted to
make
Harbor
farewell
hello bitches gonna be alright
he sure is dog what you own bitch
so Affleck takes a hit by enemy planes
and is believed to be dead
Hartnett goes to deliver the bad news
yeah I'm sure he's really gone that's
why the advertisement show him in about
20 more scenes that he wasn't in yet hey
well rabbit I get the feeling Aragorn
will make it for you the two towers also
so Hartnett and Beckinsale tried to deal
with their laws of hablok I volunteered
he told me been assigned something was
trying to protect me
yeah that is so like him to protect his
buddy god
I feel like you two have shared so much
in the two maybe three scenes you had
together you know the ones that never
went over five fucking minutes oh and
speaking of which did protecting you
also include playing chicken with
expensive aircrafts putting your life
and your professional career in danger
well at least I was worth it to 86 his
girlfriend and leave her nether regions
colder that's no man's rectal
thermometer kiddo got him in from it
outsider looking in I think it's pretty
obvious that dear old Affleck is a deal
oh how close are those planes again so
we've had one romance yes what about
sick enrollments hey we got a visitor
pick up all of or three months later
Kate decides to go to the military base
in her finest evening dress to not hit
on Hartnett but somehow ends up flying
with him with her in his lap anyway yeah
I'm sure that was sanctioned hey Sarge
I'm gonna take my girlfriend up into the
air with her in my lap even though the
seatbelt can't fit around us okay just
be back by 12:00 my kids are gonna drive
the submarine tomorrow
so after their Joyride he takes her into
one of the hangars to see if his
parachute will still deploy
but then dan aykroyd yeah you heard
right dan aykroyd make it as big as
appearance since Temple of Doom alerts
of a possible oncoming attack when I was
in the Asiatic fleet the locals used to
try to get outside of a problem to try
to see the inside a bloater pearl would
devastate the Pacific fleets ability to
make war just like that symmetrical book
stacking of the Philadelphia masts
turbulence of 1947 actually the funny
thing is a coin might be one of the best
parts of the movie I mean whether you
like him as an actor or not you have to
admit he is the king of exposition any
time he's explaining something you will
always listen it's like playing chess in
the dark any rumor troop movement ship
movements spying tingle goose bump we
pay attention to it hell I could
probably take the Dark Knight more
seriously if Thackery was doing his
voice as a duly designated
representative of the city I order you
to cease any and all supernatural
activity and return forthwith to your
place of origin or to the nearest
convenient parallel dimension huh but
it's all good because team Josh seems to
be just as happy as can be with
Affleck's leftovers every moment we're
not together you're up there training
for it
yeah well I'm trying for moments like
these oh well now that's very
interesting if you're interesting cuz we
have somebody backstage who would like
to comment on this whole thing can we
bring him out here please uh uh can we
bring him great good critic that's right
Affleck just pops out of nowhere he was
gonna call eventually but if you haven't
noticed he likes to spring dramatic
bullshit at the very last minute I got
picked up by a French fishing boat huh
I wasn't occupied France I couldn't get
word out but in the middle of their
reunion Rafe
oh I was just keeping her warm for you
huh
you
so trying to fix this problem let's go
get hammered and while we're at it let's
throw some dick remarks at the people
you thought you were helping but you're
really just being a cock horse to y'all
know Danny was even good enough to look
out for my girl for me while I was gone
we thought you were dead rape life is
good ain't it man you left her to fight
somebody else this war he's only been
back for ten minutes and already hey
when you were gone too lonely inside
ever been the same for her too if you
hadn't gone none of this would have
happened this was my fault I'm here no I
don't know you volunteered you left her
behind you try to control his life let's
see what the magic 8-ball has to say
what can't argue with that things can be
right between meeting you
I just don't see how can ever be same so
how close are those planes again I go
now to fulfill my mission and my destiny
I hope it is a destiny that would bring
honor to our family Oh what because it I
thought the reading letters to their
Japanese relatives in English to throw
the enemy off so just a mere hour and a
half in we finally get our attack on the
harbour rather than just let the terror
of the attack speak for itself
let's fly by every poetic symbol of
American innocence we can find
what did you need to add me to out I
need you I need you out you all need you
all I need you I need you all your base
are belong to us okay obey them are
communications officer where are those
dashing heroes of ours while this
terrible event is going on yeah I mean
don't let the title of the movie
interrupt their love triangle little
sleep let's figure things out yeah sort
of a big problem with this isn't it I
mean at least with Titanic whether you
like it or not you see the fictional
characters interact with the real-life
characters so when the tragedy happens
you know who they are and can build
emotional connections with them here
they're in a car away from the face I
mean okay appoint fires at them but we
know the ships is where the majority of
the attack is gonna take place and thus
where we're gonna spend most of our time
but they're never on it so we never make
a connection to any of these people
dying except maybe Cooper Gooding jr.
who had a quick cameo here and there and
yeah don't get me wrong
it sucks seeing this it sucks seeing
people get killed but why waste an hour
and a half never showing who they are
you wasted it on characters who don't
exist you don't care about and aren't
even in the center of the attack yeah
great call on that but with that said I
have to admit the action for the most
part is pretty well done I mean you can
see what's going on
it's intense and the effects are very
impressive but even bei couldn't let
this pass without some bullshit moments
for example is this guy brushing his
teeth are you shitting me buddy
fuck the plaque buildup I really hope
the military doesn't teach people that
when they hear explosions run out into
fire in a bath towel oh and how about
this crap where the planes are shown
firing on civilians at a hospital even
though it was reported that the Japanese
never fired on them yeah even when they
had a clear shot they ruined not fire at
the hospital fuck that shit this is
Michael Bay's history if this is Randall
Wallace is riding the winds put Kate
Beckinsale in danger from those evil
Japs plan to fire on hospitals and kill
one of those giggling idiots that you
barely knew oh yeah I'll miss what I'm
gonna hell her name was oh and listen to
this
wait oh fuck you're telling me that a
man a soldier a sailor in the Navy
on a battle cruiser can't swim okay okay
Michael babe okay Michael America fuck
yeah I'm Michael Bay I'd do anything for
fuckin mayor can i trick it up until
it's blue just everyone you are making
our military look like undisciplined
asses I mean let me get this straight
they take women up in their planes for
joyrides use cheat sheets to pass their
eye exams which dollars are making a
fucking sense by the way pull off
dangerous ego stroking stunts and yet
somehow that gets him promoted continue
to press their teeth even when they're
under attack by the way he still had to
look he's still fucking has it
don't go protect another soldier
anything you hold on to that toothbrush
private and on top of that you make the
accusation that there are soldiers in
the military who can't swim
you know dick that's what your fucking
dick when you show this image oh the
American flag destroyed you're not just
showing your dollar-store symbolism
that's as America's hurt but it's very
clear that what is important to you is
not how you view America what is
important to you is how others see you
viewing America so you can make up
whenever you want you can fabricate
things you can lie about history you can
exaggerate you can glorify you can
demonize you can distort the facts you
can make up the truth make up the truth
about people who lost their lives in
this great tragedy why because you're
doing it in the name that you fucking
love America I'm sorry I don't fuck
around with this shit
I don't okay these are people who are
their life people have been drafted
people who volunteer people put their
asses on the line and many of them don't
come back you're taking upon yourself to
show that and I know what you're
thinking yeah you're thinking well I'll
just make up people because they weren't
really there so I can do whatever I want
with them I can make shit up and uh
granted you don't deserve the
responsibility to show real events you
don't live in the real world but what
happened is that when you take it and
base our real event you have to show
these real people you have to get a ride
Michael Bay you have to get it right
because this this isn't transformers
okay that that's kid shit you can do
whatever you want it's not the rock it's
not Joe can we say winners fuck the prom
queen oh it's fucking Pearl Harbor
reality it actually happened and I know
you're thinking about well it's
Hollywood we take liberties fuck you
it's not Hollywood when you take it upon
yourself to represent something that
really happened and it's still painful
and hurts a lot of people that means you
have to do two things one you have to
grow up and be an adult too
you have to actually represent these
people as best as humanly possible yeah
son of a -
I can't be the only one who sees this
and thank God I wasn't don't look at me
I didn't hate the guy I know the movie
bombed only there was throwing money at
it
I didn't chose a director but Peter I
was here in the room and you hired him I
told you I never heard of the guy never
heard Michael Bay now get out of here go
why are you taking me
your secretary wishes it to be known
that there's an offer for free hugs him
what kind of sadistic man is this making
this I like practicing I've never seen
this guy it's just gonna mean just kill
yourself so what went wrong mr. BAE I
don't know this was supposed to be my
big epic masterpiece but not only do all
the critics hated but audiences hated -
that's real tough brittle skittle that
is really tough all the world hates me
and now I had to carry my burden Oh
what's that all the pro hardware DVDs
they suspected that nobody would ever
buy one so they gave them all to me
would you guys like one
then I must leave you goodbye
you
ah
Oh truly this man was the son of schlock
so President Roosevelt and his rubber
double-chin plan to fight back and
finally enter into war I'm talking about
hitting the heart of Japan the way they
have hit us what you're asking
can't be done oh no oh no yeah no no you
did it again
ah don't you suffer that you suffer
there rose event no use not used I know
you care about my vision and oh I'm
fuckin Delano Roosevelt biatch
do not tell me it can't be done that is
so damn cliched but you know what it's
FDR I'll give it a pass that's one of
the most incredible motherfuckers who
ever lived I I'm surprised his
wheelchair didn't turn to a transformer
fire consumes the cabinet and his theme
song plays ammo it's the one time I
watching Michael Bay go more than the
top I'm not gonna lie I can't find Danny
damn why are you here oh crap I forgot
about this horseshit there's no more
Japanese bomber planes to save me now
well you don't have to explain anything
to me I do because you're acting like I
didn't love you everyone loving you kept
me alive
it just didn't keep me from leaving you
but it turns out Kate has an even bigger
secret
Reef I'm pregnant
told Danny I don't wanted to know all he
needs to think about is how to do this
mission and get back alive kids and as
any soldier will tell you a loving woman
by your side and child on the way
wouldn't be a good motivator at all
should offer ice cream ice cream so once
again Affleck and Hartnett are assigned
together
backward and once again Doolittle tries
to see if he can talk with the animals I
need you for a mission I've been ordered
to put together you know what top secret
is it's not quite as complicated as your
million dollar French words but I think
you can deduce what it means and if it
doesn't seem pretty ridiculous asking
grown men what words that even a
five-year-old would recognize means how
about asking grown men to listen to a
speech that even a five-year-old would
write oh and I'm yet every overused
cliched phrase ever used in a speech is
used in this dialogue life this is a
dangerous mission the mission I'm asking
you to volunteer for is exceptionally
dangerous look to the man next to you
he'll be dead take a look at the man
beside you you or he will be dead the
victory belongs to those who believe in
it the most victory belongs to those
that believe in it the most I think
these people might disagree but screw it
and let's end with the most cliched of
all I shit you not those who are brave
enough step forward
everyone brave enough to accept this
step forward
do we honestly have a choice if we've
been drafted okay look at those brave
American men who can do no wrong
watch as they kill innocent civilians on
there dangerous raid oh wait we're not
going to show that part I really haven't
okay um well Nicky's let me show you the
part that didn't happen when those evil
Japanese fired on our civilians at the
hospital it's true history is written by
the winners or people so secure about
how good their country is that they have
to constantly edit it to remind you how
good it is but after their raid they
crash land in China where Japanese
armies are winning
this makes athletes gun growl really it
growls and heart that is shot in the
crossfire daddy you can't die but you
can't die you know why because you're
gonna be a father don't be a daddy I was
supposed to take uh I wish she told me
that would have been a great motivator
not to be shot
good
so Hartnett kicks the bucket the Chinese
come to rescue them Affleck tells the
news to Kate who takes it pretty well
and I guess our whole role in this movie
is just beat old men are dead and they
have their child off screen
I just like to go fly yeah enough you're
dead daddy there's a plane we can fly
and it doesn't really even end on that
big of a note I just the film knew that
was the audience had to pee or already
walked out so they just are slapped the
credits over it and that was a terrible
movie
you know those crappy after-school
specials that want to talk to you about
drugs but clearly have no idea what
they're talking about that's sort of
like Michael Bay in history if you want
to a horrible love story fine but leave
our dead soldiers out of it because in
the end it doesn't work as good fiction
and it doesn't work as good answer and
honestly it's just strange that Michael
Bay would even try it
I mean clearly his niche is box office
crap not historical drama I mean that's
his calling it's always bet his calling
I wanna really realize that
hello hey where you been man we've been
worried sick about you
tell my a big boo Tina said she has big
boobs why would that forget it guys the
crowd has spoken nobody wants to see
what I'm best at
bitch that's cracker talk maybe the
thing you're best at isn't romances are
representing history or any sort of
reality for that matter what are you
talking about the bay I know didn't give
a shit about emotions or character or
anything like that the bay I know please
the lowest common denominator and went
all the way with it
it's like when we did porn you just gave
the people what they want what you say
it's like when we did for remember I do
Thank You doc you've inspired me once
again hello okay gonna take a risk on
you one more time
good because I have a new way to change
Hollywood what how would you like to get
every perverted manchild in the world to
see your movie that's every producer's
dream well I think I figured out a way
to make it happen how
make it all porn me like big breasted
women everywhere no well yes but go
beyond that make everything that you
shoot in the movie like it's a woman
taking her clothes off I don't follow
that chair over there
I can shoot it like it's porn with low
angle shots slo-moes zoom ins I can make
it look absolutely Oh erotic any time
you see an explosion shoot it like it's
porn any time you see an American flag
waving shoot it like it's born I bet I
can even make the sunset look like it's
porn and long I shall call it
Poornima Tok Rafi
you shoot everything like it's warm
without actually showing porn we can
sell it to a 13 year old demographic yes
but how about how it ties it to the
story it doesn't make any logical Sun so
world doesn't make any logical sense the
only thing constant is poor it must be
this way oh one more thing I require my
own crew
mr. BAE don't think that's much safety a
toe will hurt people I imported mr. BAE
do you really think we can throw in this
mini explosion torn it forever cordage
is just too much damn slow mo and then
Hornet but the people won't watch Hornet
do you realize what this means
yes yes risen and behold the second
coming of crap give not into character
give not into story for that leads to
art give instead unto born from Lord is
everlasting and shall never diminish
from the earth and always remember if
you're going to suck suck all the way
but I can speculate I'm the Nostalgia
Critic I remember so you don't have to
you
they call it an homage sir a what